are you doing school for yourself or
you're doing it for your parents
probably more like 70 for them 30 for me
would they be devastated if you bounced
my dad probably would I think
the answer is you don't want to do it
you wouldn't have brought it up to me if
you did are you collecting debt starting
next year I would you can't do that yeah
you can't you gotta say Dad I love you
this isn't for me and I can't take on
personal debt or something that's not me
I've been doing it for you because I
love you but I can't take on the step he
may say I'll pay for it then you have a
different decision to make but you can't
make a decision of doing something you
don't want to do to collect on that you
can't do that